s'allumant ça va oui ça va qu'est ce qui
se passe avec ta voix oui c'est parce
que comme ça les panneaux papillon j'ai
pris une cravate à aillas tout mayol en
fait
[Musique]
la semaine dernière je vous ai raconté
comment j'ai perdu ma voix comment je
n'ai retrouvé mais pas complètement est
ce que j'ai fait pour comprendre ce qui
s'était passé et pour essayer d'arranger
les choses
si vous n'avez pas vu cette vidéo vous
n'avez pas pu comprendre la merveilleuse
blague de romain dans l'intro et vous ne
pouvez pas savoir non plus qu'à la fin
de cette vidéo je vous avais promis de
revenir plus en détail sur ce truc
merveilleux est beau et des fois pas du
tout mais en tout cas toujours
mystérieux la voit ici la voix voyons
tout ça avec des trucs à savoir sur
votre droit alors on en avait déjà parlé
dans mon tuto pour apprendre à roter sur
commande mais on va se pencher quand
même tout de suite sur cette toute
première question comment on fait de
parler
vous savez sûrement ça on parle grâce à
nos cordes vocales
mais est ce que vous savez vraiment
comment ça marche non bon voilà
laissez-moi vous éclairer vos cordes
vocales
elles sont dans votre cou dans votre
larynx pour être précis qui est un
organe en cartilage tapissé de muqueuses
et les cordes vocales c'est des replis
de cette muqueuse avec des muscles et
des ligaments
d'ailleurs on les appelle les plis
vocaux donc c'est pas du tout des cordes
d'ailleurs en vrai ça y ressemble mais
pas ça ressemble à ça voilà ça c'est les
miennes vous voyez ça ressemble plutôt à
voyez ça ressemble à un oeil de petit
animal mignon qui dort voilà alors qui
décorait une bonne conjonctivite là oui
bon de toute façon c'est pas la question
bon alors donc quand vous inspirer de
l'air dont cordes vocales elles sont
vertes l'air qui passe par la trachée il
va jusque dans vos poumons et quand vous
expirez pareil mais dans l'autre sens
mais si vous décidez de dire un truc vos
cordes vocales
elle se rapproche et l'air en passant au
milieu il les fait vibrer et ça produit
un son ensuite se sont ils et amplifier
la juste au dessus dans le pharynx c'est
à dire dans les cavités de la bouche et
du nez
et pour finir en fonction de la façon
dont vous placez votre bouche notre
langue vaut dans vos lèvres sa forme des
phonèmes des syllabes des mots vous
parler ou vous chantez
ouais il avait vu sa demande quand même
pas mal de boulot à votre corps non plus
être réfléchie c'est un petit peu avant
de vous lancer pensez aux autres
pourquoi on a la voix grave
oui eh ben je vous le donne en mille
c'est une question de taille comme quoi
des fois ça compte plus les cordes
vocales sont longue et épaisse plus la
voix est grave mais ce n'est pas tout
plus elles sont situées basse dans le
coup plus la voix est grave et plus
elles sont hautes plus la voix aiguë
d'ailleurs on peut modifier la hauteur
de sa voie en faisant travailler son
larynx
quand on se force à avoir la voix aiguë
y remonte je ne peux pas vous le faire
et pour la voix grave du coup il
redescend globalement pour toutes les
caractéristiques de votre voix et du
grave donc mais aussi le rock voile est
clair forte faible nasillarde
ça dépend de votre morphologie c'est à
dire que ça dépend de la taille et de la
forme de votre larynx de votre pharynx
de la langue de la bouche etc
ça dépend aussi d'autres facteurs comme
votre posture la taille de vos poumons
mais aussi le facteur psychologique
comme nous la timidité par exemple pour
parler que de ça et puis bien sûr il ya
aussi l'histoire de l'alcool et du tabac
qui joue mais ça on va en parler plus
tard pourquoi la mue vers la
transformation de la voix vu que ça se
passe à l'adolescence nous en douter
c'est encore un coup de main quasi ce
n'est pas lui c'est encore un coup des
hormones au moment de la puberté a
déclenché une série de changements au
niveau de la morphologie des organes
génitaux mais aussi de la voix sous
l'effet de ces hormones le larynx et les
cordes vocales s'agrandissent donc la
voie on l'a vu et de bien plus grave
et comme ça se passe sur une période
assez courte à on parle de six mois un
an maximum c'est pas toujours facile de
contrôler un organe qui change de taille
aussi vite c'est ce qui explique que
pendant la mue les ados ont un peu de
mal à maîtriser la hauteur de leur poids
est alors au cas où vous en douteriez
tout le monde nous les filles comme les
garçons mais c'est vrai qu'à ce niveau
là c'est plus spectaculaire chez les
garçons passent en moyenne leurs voix
des sons d'une octave c'est-à-dire de
huit notes alors que chez les filles
c'est une tiers c'est à dire
pourquoi on est en haut ça vous dit sans
doute déjà arrivé d'avoir la voix cassée
soit parce que vous avez trop crié soit
parce que vous avez parlé trop longtemps
soit parce que vous êtes malade ça
s'appelle une dysphonie alors ça veut
juste dire que votre voix marche pas
bien mais tout de suite ça fait des
trucs sérieux donc ça peut vous servir
ses cadeaux dans la majorité des cas
c'est votre larynx et vos cordes vocales
qui sont irrités soit par un truc que
vous avez respirer soit par l'alcool ou
la cigarette soit parce que vous avez
trop forcé soit par une bactérie ou un
virus
dans tous les cas ça crée une réaction
de défense de l'organisme que vous
connaissez bien maintenant si vous me
suivez régulièrement l'inflammation en
gros ça gonfle et ça marche plus
correctement
ça va du simple petit voilà la phonie
total mais dans la majorité des cas ça
se soigne plutôt bien sauf si vous ne
supprimez pas la cause
là je parle du tabac et de l'alcool par
exemple ou si la cause des chroniques
comme une malformation par exemple un
adultère une petite boule ou une tumeur
ça peut se soigner aussi mais c'est plus
complexe que pour une sainte
inflammation pourquoi on est prêt
il ya des gens qui n'ont plus du tout
usage de la parole la plupart du temps
c'est lié à une surdité mais il peut
aussi y avoir une atteinte des cordes
vocales ça peut être une paralysie des
cordes vocales à cause d'un problème
neurologique par exemple ou à cause
d'une tumeur et puis ça peut être parce
qu'on a plus de cordes vocales du tout
parce qu'on nous a retiré le larynx et
tout ce qu'il ya dedans à cause d'un
cancer
sans oublier les causes psychologiques
comme certains gros traumatisme par
exemple qui peuvent déboucher sur un
mutisme mais aussi des troubles du
développement des retards mentaux des
atteintes cérébrales comme les avc ou
des traumatismes au crâne
dans tous les cas comme toujours pour
soigner faut trouver la cause et pour la
trouver au fait pourquoi on ne se
reconnaît pas quand on entend sa voix
enregistrée vous connaissez le truc
parker vous entendez votre voix
enregistrée vous vous reconnaissez pas
tout de suite
et quand vous finissez par accepter le
fait que ok c'est bien vous vous aimez
pas du tout votre voix parce qu'elle
n'est pas comme vous avez l'habitude de
l'entendre
d'abord bon c'est vrai un enregistrement
ça modifie toujours qu'un petit peu la
voix mais c'est pas le vrai problème
parce que tout le monde trouve que oui
c'est votre voies habituelles sauf vous
ce qui se passe c'est que quand vous
entendez la voix de quelqu'un d'autre
elle vous ai transmises par l'air elle
arrive jusqu'à votre oreille fait vibrer
votre teint pont puis des petits
osselets qui la transmettent à l'oreille
interne qui la transforme en influx
nerveux qui remonte jusqu'au cerveau par
le nerf auditif
mais quand vous entendez votre propre
voix évidemment il ya cette transmission
aérienne mais il ya aussi ce qu'on
appelle la transmission solide yens par
les os du crâne
par exemple vous savez comme les casques
à conduction osseuse pour écouter de la
musique
sauf que là c'est par l'intérieur le
truc c'est que cette voix solide jan
elle est plus grave
donc quand vous entendez votre voix
enregistrée qui vous ai transmises par
voie aérienne
là où il a trouvé plus aiguë en tout cas
vous la trouvez différente de d'habitude
et vous aimez pas trouvé sa voie la dtcc
fini pour aujourd'hui on se retrouve
très vite pour de nouvelles vidéos
d'ici là prenez soin de vous et prenez
soin des autres
mettez vous bien et surtout portez vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]